إذا كان هناك نقطة الصفر
لإعادة افتتاح دبي هنا ، فإن دبي مول في
ظل برج خليفة ،
سيعود أطول برج في العالم بحذر
إلى الحياة في الأسبوع الأول على طريق
العودة إلى متاجر التجزئة الطبيعية Nilesh التي تغذيها
ما يقرب من 1800 متجر في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة  يقول إن الإمارات العربية المتحدة تتخذ النهج الصحيح
، أعني أن العقلية هي مساعدة واضحة جدًا
قبل الأعمال أو الاقتصاد ، وبمجرد
أن نصلح ، فهذا هو الوقت المناسب
الآن لإصلاح الاقتصاد ونمضي
قدمًا ولكن التوازن صحيح ،
يكون الرصيد مائة  النسبة المئوية الصحيحة
لهذا المجمع بأكمله يستوعب أكثر من
80 مليون شخص سنويًا حوالي ربع
مليون يوميًا ولكن في هذا
الواقع السري الجديد يقتصر على 30 في المائة من
السعة العادية وحتى الآن لم
نقترب منه بعد أن وصلنا إلى حد
24  - فترة الإغلاق لساعات ،
تُبدي إمارة براش حذرًا شديدًا في
مركز التسوق.
للعالم الخارجي أن
هذه الإمارة التي بنت سمعتها
على هياكل جريئة يمكن أن تبدأ في الارتفاع
مرة أخرى ، قوضت Kovat 19
الإنفاق الاستهلاكي وأطاحت بالساقين من
تحت سوق النفط بينما
تقع أبو ظبي المجاورة على رأس معظم
عائدات النفط في دبي والشرق.
لا يزال الشرق بشكل عام معتمداً بشكل مفرط
على الثروة التي أنشأها ، ويتوقع صندوق النقد
الدولي أن هذه المنطقة ستشهد
انخفاضاً في عائدات النفط بأكثر من 250 مليار
دولار في عام 2020 ، وليس من المتوقع حدوث عودة سريعة ،
لكنني أخشى
أن تظل المنطقة رهينة
لخفض أسعار النفط لفترة أطول ، وكان
هذا الانتعاش السريع بالنسبة لي
مفاجأة بعض الشيء ، لقد كان جون طبيعيًا جديدًا غير
طبيعي طالما أننا نتفهم
أننا سنواجه هذا الصعود والهبوط ،
وسنكون بخير والناس كذلك  أعتقد
أنه سيكون هناك خط مستقيم
لن يمر عبر السنوات التي
واجهت فيها هذه المنطقة العديد من التحديات
في الحرب الإيرانية العراقية وحرب الخليج والنفط والممتلكات
ولكن التصنيف  يقول قادة الأعمال إن
هذا الوباء العالمي موجود في
رابطة جون تيفت أرياس سي إن إن دبي